los hospitales en francia están
alcanzando el punto de saturación este
martes ocho pacientes fueron trasladados
en ambulancia aérea desde el sureste de
francia a la región del loira en el
norte del país a unos 600 kilómetros de
distancia estos traslados entre
hospitales son un intento de aliviar la
presión en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos en las regiones más afectadas
del país el portavoz del gobierno dijo
que el país estaba viendo un aumento
exponencial en el número de infecciones
gastando nadie está en contra de nuestro
objetivo que es evitar que nuestros
hospitales lleguen a un punto en el que
no puedan admitir nuevos pacientes o
para decirlo muy claramente donde tienen
que elegir entre los pacientes nadie
puede aceptar eso como se ha dicho antes
la vida por encima de todo no suscribe
el 27 de octubre francia registró 33 mil
417 nuevos casos confirmados de
coronavirus aunque los médicos temen que
la cifra real sea mucho mayor en las
últimas 24 horas hubo 532 nuevas muertes
por corona virus
es la cifra más alta desde el 22 de
abril el número de pacientes de kobe 19
que ingresan al hospital en toda francia
también está aumentando acercándose a
los números que se vieron por última vez
durante la primera ola algunos
hospitales tienen tan poco personal que
incluso a los médicos y enfermeras que
han detectado el kobe 19 se les pide que
entren a trabajar los pacientes con ido
ocupando actualmente más de la mitad de
las aproximadamente 5 mil 800 camas de
cuidados intensivos de francia durante
la primera ola de la primavera los
hospitales de todo el país se vieron
obligados a cancelar las operaciones
normales y rechazaron a los pacientes
con otras enfermedades como cáncer
enfermedades cardíacas o diabetes ahora
se encuentran con que tienen que
cancelar de nuevo los tratamientos que
podrían salvar vidas para hacer frente
al aumento de los casos de kobe 19